Hey Vsauce, Michael here,
and a hemispherectomy
is a surgical procedure
in which half of a person's brain
is removed.
It's usually only ever done
on very, very young patients
because their brains are still plastic enough
that the remaining half
will take on the functions
of the half that was removed.
And it's usually done
because a young child or a baby
is having seizures, and removing
the part where the seizures occur
is the only solution.
But here's my question.
If you can live with half a brain,
what if I were to take two empty skulls
and take one half of your brain
and plop it into one body
and the other half
and put it in another body,
which person would be you?
I mean, you are you.
You are conscious.
You are aware of what is happening to you
from the perspective of yourself.
Think of it this way.
If you just stare at something
and kind of feel
what it feels like to be you,
it feels a little bit like you're a thing
inside a body looking out through the eyeballs.
And nobody else on Earth
will ever see the world from that position.
This awareness of your own experiences,
the awareness that you are having them,
the awareness that you
are having your own thoughts
makes up what we call consciousness.
But if I were to take your brain
and split it into two
and put it into two different people,
would both of them be new people
who were conscious?
Well, one of the best places to start
when defining consciousness
and understanding it
is to begin with things that we agree
are not conscious.
For instance, Cleverbot.
Cleverbot.com is an amazing website
where a computer program will respond
to your questions really cleverly
but only because it is programmed to do so.
We wouldn't consider it conscious
because it doesn't have a sense of itself.
It doesn't feel anything.
It doesn't have its own inner life.
It's just a program that responds
automatically to my inputs.
Now I know that I am not like Cleverbot.
I know that I feel things
and that I have a sense of myself.
I have intentions.
But how do I know that you do?
For that matter, how do I know
that everybody else that I meet is like me?
How do I know that they're not
just little smart versions of Cleverbot
who know exactly what to automatically say?
Now what I'm asking is incredibly philosophical,
but it is a very famous and important question.
I'm basically asking if it's possible
for something to exist
as a philosophical zombie.
That's right, a thing that reacts and responds
and acts just like a normal human
but yet doesn't actually feel anything.
It doesn't know that it's having its own thoughts.
It just automatically responds like a robot
in the appropriate way.
Now what's amazing and heavy about this question
is that science doesn't have an answer,
and it's not even clear that science
will ever have an answer,
let alone an approach to finding that answer.
About all we have is the psychology
of disorders of consciousness.
Let's begin with anosognosia.
A common example of anosognosia
in psychology classes
is a patient who has, say, lost the ability
to move their left hand.
When asked to raise their right hand,
they'll say, "Yeah, no problem, here you go."
But then when asked to raise their left hand,
they'll say, "Oh, yeah, sure, no problem,"
but not move it.
And when asked why they didn't move their left hand,
instead of reporting that they can't,
they'll confabulate some excuse.
For instance, "Oh, I didn't feel like it."
Anton-Babinski Syndrome
is even more dramatic.
Patients with this syndrome
are cortically blind.
They cannot see anything.
But they deny being blind.
If you ask them a question, for instance,
"How many fingers am I holding up?"
they will make a guess,
but if they're wrong,
they'll explain their inaccuracy
with an excuse.
For instance, "oh, well, I don't have my glasses."
People who exhibit anosognosia
tend to be the victims of stroke,
and there's some disconnect
between what they're really experiencing
and their conscious awareness of it.
They don't know that they can't see
because the part of their brain
that monitors visual input
isn't telling the brain anything.
It's not even telling the brain
that there is no visual input
which means that the parts of their brain
responsible for answering questions
or creating speech
has to completely create
a confabulated response.
Despite the fact that we've been able to study
patients with anosognosia,
we still have no idea
how to solve our original problem.
In fact, all we've managed
to come up with
are more impossible questions
about identity,
questions that are so befuddling,
the best you can do with them
is to answer them yourself
according to what you believe.
Here's another one.
It's called the Swampman.
Imagine that I'm walking
around in a swamp
and then all of a sudden,
I get struck by a bolt if lightening
and my entire body is burned to a crisp,
dissolved into smithereens.
But the very same moment,
a second bolt of lightening strikes nearby,
and it causes a bunch of atoms and molecules
to all arrange themselves
into the exact same configuration
that my body used to have,
making a second Michael.
Is that me? Would that be me?
Here's an even better one.
Imagine that a surgeon came in,
and he started removing cells
from me and from you,
replacing them exactly one at a time,
replacing my cells into your body
and your cells into my body.
At what point would I
officially have become you?
No one on Earth has the definitive answers
to these questions,
but you know what we do have?
A lean back.
That's right. I've made a playlist
of some of my favorite clips from all over YouTube
of psychology experiments and illusions
and all sorts of fun stuff
that deal with consciousness.
All you have to do is click the link
at the top of this video's description
and then lean back and let the automatic playlist
do the work for you.
I'll see you over there, and as always,
thanks for watching.
Hey Kevin, any new YouTube messages?
Actually yes. I just got this message
over at Vsauce 2
from a user who doesn't create videos
but he organizes them in his own playlists.
Yeah, yeah, that's excellent
because there's so many videos on YouTube,
we need people to help organize them,
especially by type.
Imagine a channel of playlists ranging
from cool songs to listen to when it rains
or best explosions ever.
Exactly. If you make a playlist
that you think is really cool
and full of stuff that we should know about,
send it to Michael@Vsauce.com
and we'll feature the ones we really like
because you have made YouTube
a better more organized place.
And after all, Vsauce is kind of like a carpool lane.
We're all going to get
to the cool stuff faster
because we're traveling together.
Where did you get that?